[No sounds]
Houses and rooms are full
of perfumes, the shelves are
crowded with perfumes,
I breathe the fragrance myself
and know it and like it,
The distillation would intoxicate
me also, but I shall not let it.
The atmosphere is not a
perfume, it has no taste of the
distillation, it is odorless,
It is for my mouth forever,
I am in love with it,
I will go to the bank by the
wood and become undisguised
and naked,
I am mad for it to be
in contact with me.
The smoke of my own breath,
Echoes, ripples, buzz'd whispers,
love-root, silk-thread, crotch and
vine,
My respiration and inspiration,
the beating of my heart, the
passing of blood and
air through my lungs..
Stop this day and night with
me and you shall possess the
origin of all poems,
You shall possess the good of
the earth and sun, (there are
millions of suns left,)
You shall no longer take things
at second or third hand, nor
look through the eyes of the dead,
nor feed on the spectres in books,
You shall not look through my
eyes either, nor take things
from me,
You shall listen to all sides
and filter them from your self.
[Techno Music]